train wreck inside out - monster smash
thank you good for you
wife something you're having an
incredible summer and then for most
people that's enough for like a couple
years you also do this show documentary
now which I have watched and it is
absolutely hilarious
thank you just great you Fred Armisen
this thing is so yes me and Fred Armisen
and Seth Meyers and and it's kind of
this we took documentaries existing
documentaries and recreated them but
with Fred and I in them and you know
it's our pitch to IFC and you start
throwing money at us yeah all the real
cash comes from buying IFC were just
like yeah it was funny you and and Fred
dress up as women that's called for
sometimes because I've seen some of that
there's some of the ads out there where
you're dressed as women yeah and there
you go we're looking at you there you go
you guys look very good as women I will
say and then we noticed that you look
almost exactly as you as a woman as a
woman you look just like Harry Styles I
don't know
you've been feeling my look for a very
long time
dear muta steals my night money my kids
don't like that cuz that billboards all
over LA and we drive around my kids my
three daughters like little kids and it
really confuses them seeing aggressive
women like that's daddy working yeah
daddy at work don't you worry about that
breeds of My Little Pony books don't
worry about that wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]